hello everyone your boy is back doing
another morning recording so his
roommate doesn't find out about his
channel additionally i'm feeling a lot
of self-pity and shame today because i'm
extremely hungover after a night of
heavy drinking and then ultimately
killing my diet by getting 711 taquitos
with that being said this axe is a
perfect time for me to make a very quick
video about gossip protocol so we can
talk about cassandra tomorrow let's get
into this because i want to be done
alrighty gossip protocols what is it
anytime that we have a bunch of nodes in
any different type of cluster a lot of
times we want to be able to pass
information directly from node to node
this is basically in
in contrast to something like a
coordination or a membership service
which is one centralized and perhaps
even consensus service if you want it to
be fault tolerant which keeps track of
information about nodes in a cluster
like i said gossip protocols are when
nodes actually pass information directly
amongst themselves and it's kind of
modeled after the spread of an
infectious disease which means that each
node is going to pass some information
to another node which passes some
information to a few other nodes and you
know the goal is to get it to spread
quickly over time the reason why this is
useful
at least in my case is that like i said
tomorrow i want to make a video about
apache cassandra and cassandra uses
gossip protocol as kind of its main
method of determining nodes in the
cluster and whether or not they've
failed so i think i'm going to quickly
explain gossip protocol and then we can
do a deeper dive into cassandra tomorrow
okay so let's visualize it it's pretty
simple for the most part all we're going
to do is pick a few nodes randomly
broadcast any message that the original
node has to them keep in mind the only
time you're going to be doing new
broadcasts is on the first time you
receive the message so
we have this black node here this is the
first one to have the message you know
say it gets some heartbeat from another
node and it's like okay i want to tell
all the other nodes that i just received
this heartbeat so we're going to pick
two nodes randomly and broadcast it to
them
okay so as you can see now we have two
other infected nodes
both of which are going to also tell two
nodes now you can see the top node here
is going to tell the original node again
just randomly so the original node is
not going to rebroadcast
but it is the case
that the um
at the top node is still going to reach
one other new node so now we've got
three new nodes infected in the next
round which you're going to go ahead and
randomly keep trying to tell other nodes
and eventually boom okay everyone knows
about the message which is great as you
can see in large clusters after a few
rounds of running this gossip protocol
we can generally get our messages all
around
so why is this useful in cassandra well
basically it's used to pass details
about node membership and failure in a
cluster so what are we actually passing
in the gossip protocol each node is
basically gossiping with the other nodes
regarding its own load so it's saying
here's my local state this is how i'm
doing in terms of you know like how many
rights i'm taking in and um you know if
i'm kind of like looking like i'm going
to crash soon
each node is also receiving heartbeats
from other nodes um incrementally via
this gossip protocol and it's going and
saying okay i've received a heartbeat
here's the timestamp of the heartbeat
that i received
and um keep in mind though that
obviously the issue with these
timestamps is that
server timestamps are not always
coordinated so that can be problematic
there in terms of ordering the messages
but that's just something to keep in
mind
and then other nodes upon receiving the
gossip will use those time stamps to
basically say okay you know i see that
node 1 received a heartbeat at 12
o'clock but node 2 received a heartbeat
from this other node at 1 o'clock so
i'll keep the 1 o'clock timestamp and
that's the most recent anyone's ever
heard from that note
and so it's going to hold on to that
timestamp and basically use those
timestamps for each node locally to try
and guess if that node is still up or
not so if all of the nodes are assuming
that a node is down because no one's
received a heartbeat from it and say an
hour
then eventually they'll stop sending
rights to it
so yeah i mean that's that's basically
how gossip protocol gets used in
cassandra but generally speaking gossip
protocol is just a good low overhead
system for communicating messages to a
bunch of nodes in a cluster and it's got
relatively low overhead and coordination
we're not using any membership services
it's really good for using uh or for
doing failure detection like i said
but obviously it's not perfect it's not
every node is reaching consensus at the
same exact time it's going to take a bit
for those messages to get propagated and
then furthermore the messages are not
being delivered in order if a bunch of
nodes are gossiping their own messages
then those can come in out of order and
you have to use something like time
stamps or vector clocks to perform the
ordering of the messages and determine
which to keep and which to throw away
okay that was a quick one
i'm actually dying right now so yeah
have a good one and i'll speak to you
guys